the picture that you have on your book
is something that has been associated
through the media and even us i mean i
see the book and i'm like hold on hold
on this is dangerous this is dangerous
maybe it's really maybe this book will
now explode you know and kill everybody
so what's your reaction when you see the
cover of his book
okay subhanallah
do you know who abused this this sign
and this
that's right now we are putting it back
back in the right perspective so people
don't think this is sign of some
terrorism killing this is sign of peace
son of love
mashallah mashallah what are the things
that come to your mind when you see this
isis unfortunately yeah
you think this is easy yeah
that's that's you see uh this is not
issue they
hijacked this sign this is sign of the
prophet muhammad
he's be upon him this is not sign of
israel
you said you're first what does it say
what does this mean what does this mean
yeah sure you say
the first reaction or what people think
about it right but
yeah but i know what it's about it's
like there is no god but allah
there's nothing worthy of worship except
to create allah there's no no deity
where they worship except allah
yeah it is a messenger through media
through all these institutions
it's deliberately wrongly uh percepted
by
by they accused actually the slogan and
they they made it like internationally
or something property for them
right hijacked whatever it means or
whatever
it has to say it doesn't belong to them
yeah absolutely it doesn't but media you
know
media thank you very much
greetings and peace welcome to the dean
charmed your host
and we are in sarajevo with our special
guest
marco franciscovich how are you my
brother oh fine thank you brother
assalam-o-alaikum
how you been fine finally it's been not
too long ago since we are hooked up last
time
when we met in zagreb yes now we are in
sarajevo now we're in suraj
i feel real bad i wasn't able to make it
out to zadar yeah
you got some really good historical
places you're going to take me too right
why don't we share it was very very nice
to hear
this story about this uh tree yes uh can
you tell us about that inshallah i can
see it and bring it to the viewers in
person
next time so there is a some
20 kilometers north of zadar this other
is
creation city on the adriatic coast and
some more than 300 years ago
there was the the most western border of
the ottoman empire
and on this place there was also mosque
uh and the mosque was later as
ottomans retreated back the mosque was
destroyed but the tree was planted there
this oak tree and since then until today
this uh oak tree has grown now it's it's
big it's a big tree
more than some 25 meters big
but the the miracle of this tree it
that it never goes uh
brown it's always it leaves uh always
green they're always green always green
three hundred more than three hundred
years the
the tree has leaves they don't fall off
and they are green during the winter and
all the other trees all the other oaks
the the leaves fall off the branches are
empty you know without leaves but this
the green oak is always green
with with leaves on it and this is
verifiable people can go
yeah look it up it's called what what is
the name of the tree it's called
the green oak the green oh very simple
like the natural process of trees is
that they come in season
and the leaves come out and the season
changes
yeah here seasons come and go but the
tree is constantly green
yeah and it's a it's a very biological
botanical miracle that
there is no rational explanation for
this
what's going on these are just those i
look at like signs
from from the creator you have the
ultimate signs like the quran this is
what brought you to
to islam and we talked about your story
last time then you had just have those
things that just unexplained how do you
explain that
you know what i mean you just can't this
is like just a blessing
right for me this is sign you know for
people who
hear this story see this tree hold on
stop for a minute
try to think about it what
this is something that is going uh
away from the usual uh rhythm of life
that we are pushed in you know to wake
up to
go to work to work to go home to go to
sleep
and kind of we go hypnotized by this
system but by this media
that we don't even think about broader
things you know
yeah and this is one of these moments
when we can stop and think hold on
what's going
there is something uh higher than this
basic everyday living material world
right right and some people go to the
extreme and they see that and then
they'll start end up worshiping the tree
yeah no
no no no no yeah they should worship the
creator
the creator of the tree right yeah and
some people i know there was
i don't know if you you know this uh
they had a
the scandinavians at one time they would
go ahead and knock
on the tree to wake it up to go ahead
and seek blessings from the tree and
that's where you get this people
knocking right
these that's right so you have even some
muslims have fell in the trap they're
culturally let's say we see a lot of
that you know okay i'm muslim because
you know my parents are muslim or not
and then you see them like
something happens good in their lives
and they knock you out in the world yeah
you know it's pagan pagan tradition
these are pagan traditions right
yeah so that's that's another lesson
that if we seek all blessings all
blessings are from the creator the
heavens and the earth and it's
that pure monotheism and it was
interesting when we were talking
we met up yesterday i was thinking i was
like wow we're sitting here
having these discussions intellectual
discussions you know academic
discussions you know based
to try to figure out how to disseminate
truth to people
and is that different from
where you'll have and i was like listen
we're not sitting here it was just
interesting because i can imagine some
circles where they're calling certain
people
uh dirty vile names and especially in
some of these regions and even with the
the growing trend of islamophobia where
people
like label people with most they have
this venom and hate in them
and i was just thinking i was like wow
look in these discussions that i've had
with people
there's no like uh putting down of let's
say uh
a certain group of people or whatnot
it's really out of love
trying to get truth to people but not by
by under just uh calling people dirty
disgusting names or you know
trying to you get what i'm trying to do
yeah no humility humiliate yeah yeah to
give them respect yeah even if you don't
agree with them you know
treat the other human being with respect
you know
that's the way how we can uh
better connect to each other and send
our match message to to be
received yeah because if we start you
know
with hard only hard arguments even if we
are right
even if right is on our side we have to
be
uh with some uh you know kindness with
not not to uh be brutal to our opponent
so so he we can give them a chance to to
to for them to express themselves so
their ego doesn't block them
uh in in perceptions of what we
want to say to them yeah and that's what
you uh
do in your new book you just write you
wrote a new book and you have three
chapters
to it yeah this is my new book that's
your new book
see right off the bat someone is gonna
really because the picture that you have
on your book
is something that has been associated
through the media
and even us i mean i see the book and
i'm like hold on hold on this is
dangerous this is dangerous
maybe it's really maybe this book will
now explode you know and kill everybody
and you actually have uh here uh uh
horizon is called
and now you also have not only do you
have a a provocative picture here
that's associated with you know they'll
have what will perceive this is a
terrorist let's say with this
behind his uh in the background
and then you have jihad on your book and
you go ahead and elaborate
why you put such a provocative you know
uh
exactly on your book a picture on your
book and title
right the main motive is that
these these words and these
symbols now are presented as a negative
as a as a symbol of terrorism as a
symbol of
senseless killing and it's
it's a it's a abuse of these symbols and
of this world
because the real meaning is totally
opposite
it's an uh inversion of true but we are
now living in and uh these these forces
with evil forces
they uh they're like uh criminal they
stole this from the muslims
and they put them in this negative
context and i'm saying with this book
when we discover
i'm not i'm not going to bow to you and
to your
perspective that you want to push to do
all our world
i'm i'm taking this back and i'm putting
it in the right
perspective you know you're doing a
rebranding rebranding exactly
that's the right word for example this
name jihad
now people who are you know
fed by the media they
automatically uh think uh jihad is uh
killing
of uh it's a war it's a killing you know
of other people it's a it's a conflict
but jihad is struggle within
that's the big the main jihad and it's
the hardest jihad and this is the jihad
that never ends
everybody of us we every morning when we
wake up
we go into jihad you know not to fall
into our you know weaknesses everybody
had some weaknesses
some some soft points and we have to
fight to to not to
go this way bad way to be on the right
way to
to be honorable to be fair to be nice
this is jihad yeah this is jihad with
which we
personally fight also we have uh
this is on uh individual level but also
there is
jihad on collective level as as a acting
group as a people
you know uh we have to uh
make ourselves better you know people
also individually and collectively
like to blame always somebody else for
for their problems you know
it's not my fault his fault he made me
do it they made me do it
also yes maybe they did
make some you know
some interventions but uh first
concentrate on yourself make yourself
better make yourself stronger
so you don't fall under others influence
then you know we can maybe speak about
these outside influences but first
focus on yourself make yourself better
and this is the main
main idea of jihad yeah
and this is called the big jihad and
this small jihad
when you want to defend yourselves if
somebody attacks you
this is this jihad small jihad when you
are
rightfully defending yourself from from
the attack of from if somebody attacks
you
and you have all the right to do so and
even you have the obligation
if you are a father of your family
somebody attacks your family
what will you do you will defend your
family but to defend it
uh in the best way you have to go
through this big
big jihad you know to make yourself
stronger
to arm yourself but are with what
when you say you have to arm yourself
everybody thinks oh you have to
take arms yes but hold on first arm
yourself spiritually
arm yourself intellectually seek
knowledge arm yourself with knowledge
and then after all this then you can
harm yourself
if you if it's needed with guns uh
whatever swords whatever is needed and
when you have this knowledge
right knowledge then you will not fall
in the trap
to go into fight with somebody who is
maybe not your real enemy maybe your
real
enemy somebody else because if you have
a lack of knowledge
you don't know how to recognize who is
your real friend who is your real
enemy so you go in to fight uh in the
wrong directions
so without good knowledge you cannot
you cannot wage uh proper war yeah
so people usually think it's such a
beautiful word
and we as muslims also those uh and i
usually define words muslims simply one
who submits his will or her will to the
creator of the heavens and earth jesus
was a muslim
abraham the last and final measure of
muhammad peace and blessing be upon him
all
they all did jihad to convey the truth
so individual jihad struggle so it's a
stroke it's not holy war
this is also a false narrative that
people push that jihad
equals holy war but you have like you
said an individual
struggle to wake up for morning prayer
how to get out of the bed but that's
your first struggle i'm tired i want to
sleep
right then the next the next one hits
you right let's say
you're you know you're trying to get
married that's a huge job right
you're trying to get married you're not
trying like the the norm is to jump from
this
man this woman promiscuity sexual
immorality to lower your gaze that is a
daily struggle every day every day you
know
some people just started practicing
islam right uh submission to the creator
not the creation
and they are used to going to the
nightclubs and their friends are calling
them up
and they're listening we'll pay your way
we'll get you through the line
we'll get you into the back door like
good fellas right through the back door
you've got to do a struggle a jihad not
to go to that place nice girls are
waiting for you you know
that's a huge struggle right so you then
you have police
uh doing jihad against the criminals
then like you were saying
at a higher level the military jihad
right the state
protect themselves from invading forces
so this is just something simple
uh jihad is in the bible right it's in
the bible right
uh it's there but so when you define
these words and not let people play with
you because you're ignorant and then
they put the smoke in your eyes
and you you know you just get hypnotized
it's very easy to understand and you
that's why you uh put it uh provoke
thought on your book
right right to provoke uh because
uh it's like aikido principle you know
yeah take you know
these uh evil forces of the world yeah
they took this
these symbols these words and they they
pushed their narrative yeah so huh
and peop through mass media through all
these institutions
they uh programmed uh
people on the mass level you know with
this uh
wrong understanding of this but then i'm
going with this i'm using
this uh what they did uh this uh
even it's it doesn't matter if that it
is
in the negative context i'm using this
negative context
to get attention you know and when i go
to attention okay
and when somebody will uh open this book
and read it
then you'll find oh it's completely
different you know
it's it's not what i heard about it's
not what they uh
told me that is you know but uh i said
i hear the principle you know don't
confront your enemy directly but take
their force
and redirect it in the right way
yeah i can go on and on it just it's
just a beautiful term a beautiful
concept struggling and striving
uh to be a right a good human being to
worship one god and one god alone and be
morally upright
ibn acclaim uh one great scholar in
islam he has 13 points
that he talks about jihad one of them is
conveying the truth
you know sharing the truth and this is
what uh you're doing through this book
i'm trying to do it in my best possible
way now someone says but
why do you have this picture
that's associated again with so much
negativity right
exactly because it is associated with
negativity
and it is wrong it is a deception they
made a big deception
with this it is symbol with this flag
you know
in all these videos you can see you know
uh
all these brutal brutal killings
senseless killings you know
which doesn't represent islam it's it's
made
so the public view would be you know
islam is uh
madness islam is doesn't want peace
islam is only about war killing
and islam is all the opposite yeah all
the opposite
yeah so they put this this you know
this symbol which is symbol of prophet
muhammad peace be
upon him uh what does it
translate what is what is being said
there
mohammed is the prophet of god
so first that that is pretty much uh
what jesus said
right moses said that every messenger
that was sent for humanity
said this statement right negation that
i'm not going to worship creation
and affirming that you only worship the
one god the creator and you see what
they did
with this holy holy message from all the
messenger of god
they put it in the negative context as a
something that we should be afraid of
yeah
i'm not i'm same i'm not let you do that
so someone hijacked
hijacking right you trying to take it
back and rebrand it right right yeah
with the truth
we should not uh submit to their terms
of engagement you know
because uh it's it's not they're not
playing fair
they're playing playing dirty and
as a muslim i see an obligation you know
to put this in the right
perspective every time i when i make the
correlation between
jesus who obviously some people in these
parts they don't know that you
to be a muslim you have to believe in
jesus is one of the mightiest messengers
ever sent to mankind he never ever
we have a challenge to this day you'll
get paid a hundred thousand dollars if
you could ever show where he ever said
i'm god worship me
you won't find it but he did say he said
there's nothing worthy of worship except
the one god
it's in the lord's prayer our father who
are in heaven hallowed be thy name
he is attributing all power to the
creator uh
i believe it's in god uh john 17 3 where
he said this is life eternal that they
may know you the only true god
and jesus who of you have sent he was a
messenger sent by god
he proclaimed this uh if you were living
during his time you would have to say
that and then instead of saying muhammad
rasool allah you would say isa
jesus the messenger of allah musa moses
the messenger at his time
today the final messenger is prophet
muhammad
uh until the end of time and you have
and this is what led you you looked at
the proof and the evidence
right it wasn't just an emo you know
something where you blocked your mind
you had to go up against a lot to make
that decision if this was really the
truth
right right because uh it brought it
brought on me you know
very a lot of hardship yes yes
but uh it's worth you know because uh
the final final award yeah is enormous
you're a true warrior
a warrior in the sense you know they had
this uh this navy seal he wrote a book
for kids
and he talks about you know uh being a
warrior standing on good principles you
know
being uh honest upright and many people
they'll get in a cage let's say and
fight and i see him
but when it comes to standing for truth
you know you got people fighting in
backyards man
you know i fought i fought when i had to
count how many fights i had on the
street it
it can pass 50. you know right people
that's just a part of sometimes you know
we think courage is sitting here and
just throwing a few punches
but that's the greatest jihad is let me
see if you're going to be a man in the
ring you can fight but let me see when
the truth is to be conveyed are you
going to buckle by your knees right
that's a warrior and to not only but to
say the truth
in the face of the somebody who has the
lots of power
to to the face of pharaoh yeah so you
being there in zagreb being an uh by
you're just a man by yourself almost you
know what i mean
you have a communities you know small
community but man this is a warriorship
you're a warrior brother
and you see it's funny you you haven't
read this book you know
but the book begins
with words exactly here
he says i'm a warrior oh
warrior you would say this is like this
is the beginning of the book
yeah you know and i then i explained the
meaning of that
exactly what you said you were speaking
like you read the book but you didn't i
didn't read the book
i didn't read the book we're taking
those terms and that's why i mentioned
this navy seal jocko
he's famous back from motivational and
he talks about
like god state he talks about and this
is the kids book
you know and he talks about these terms
and it's like wow it's like if we talk
about this
it's like hold on if muslims talk about
warrior if they talk about some of these
concepts
jihad struggling striving for
righteousness they're going to be like
man this guy's terrorists what's going
on
but as soon as someone else it's like
they took these concepts from islam
it's okay right it's but with us it's
off limits so you're
reclaiming these things reclaiming it
back god willing it will
get back in the right perspective and
because the
truth is on our side so essentially
we don't have to put because when
somebody is lying
he always says has to think what what
did i say
i have to remember you know what trick
did they use but when you are telling
the truth
it's easy you you you can so easily
always repeat you don't get in
contradictions you know
you're not you're much more uh your mind
is more free
to to to speak you know yeah
what i tell usually people because
there's so many things that we can talk
about as humans
but one thing i really highly say look
look look please because
if we lie about god well how can you
trust us on anything else
so look at the concept of god in islam
look at this pyramid just look at what
we're talking about
the creator and see if it fits with your
with your nature your instinct
compass moral compass and then from
there if that makes sense
everything else will slowly fall in
place but if you can't get this right a
lot of things are but then also you have
other people
because you had for instance the uh the
uncle of the prophet
right right uh he he didn't accept islam
but we he supported the deen so then you
also have people like
because it's god almighty is the one who
guides you you have abu talib but then
you have abu jahl right
so just so people open minded good
hearted people can sit and
like we were talking about earlier that
some people there's so many layers of
layers of darkness
right that people have been programmed
you know to to believe you know
something that's
totally the opposite but if we can get
people to you know
to see us islam in action to our good
manners in the clock
and then we can connect even if they
disagree you know they want to worship a
tree go ahead but they see that we stand
for justice we stand for morality the
good things wholesome things
like we had owen benjamin this christian
yeah he used to bash islam and
everything
now he's he's someone who became went
from abu jahl
right he's speaking good we made this
connection yeah i saw this show it was a
great
great show and
what you're saying is exactly right yeah
tell me uh in there now so we know what
islam stands for
we know what our mission is is to
promote goodness
worship of one god morality uh and all
these things
that are just if it connects with human
beings and the opposite you portray you
show in your book
you know injustices oppression
and it's interesting we talked about all
these things that people attack
us on it seems like i asked the question
in 50 years
which muslim country attacked another
muslim country you know you have the
oppression of the ubers you have the
right now in kashmir
you have the palestinian issue do you
discuss some of these things
yes yes i discuss them when i have
my comments even in some interviews
and especially in this book i'm going
through this
uh historical and geopolitical
way of the world especially especially
regarding jerusalem and the
doma of the rock and the al-aqsa mosque
yeah
so you discussed that yes a lot of times
when i first heard that
i was like hold on because there's so
many like we call them rabbit holes
uh you're busy with life work you know
uh you're going about your business and
someone mentioned this third temple and
you're like
come on man i got time for this there's
some conspiracy theory
stuff but then you start researching and
you see like you know i heard this from
from others and i hear from you i say
what's going on am i not
keen and i'm about to talk about it you
know so i go investigate and this is
some
mainstream stuff uh in in in its main
pretty it's becoming mainstream it's not
mainstream in the us
but it's something that's not hidden you
don't have to
look deep no research in it just you
have to
take some time and very easily to to
find out what's going on yeah
but people don't have time even if they
have some free time
they're spending spending this time in
all these distractions i don't know
nba football whatever you know
there are lots of these distractions
where spin people spend
their free time instead of researching
the the essential and
important things for them for their
families and for the society
to know what's going on but if you if
you
if your life goes you know worshiping
some
media from
hollywood actress uh whatever yeah kim
kardashian yeah
narcissist and then of course that you
won't
find out about third temple about you
know
usury and why your wages are so low you
know
you complain my wages is so low and
i need more money to and understand
people you know to feed my family to
to to every for every everyday living
but you have to find out why is it
why is that so what's going on why how
come that
this human progress now if you compare
for example
if you compare uh just some 100 years
ago
what we were able to do one man you know
now with all this modern technology is
uh
stronger uh he has more production
capability
than a thousand men only 100 years ago
you know all this information technology
you know now we can type in you know
to calculate something it goes in the
seconds you go the result
before all teams of men should you know
calculate by by hand you know it is it
was hard
work to do to calculate something that
we are now uh taking for granted
and the question is if now one man has a
productive capability of thousands when
before why this one man doesn't have
at least no thousand but maybe ten times
more
uh bigger salary where is the difference
who took
all these higher
productivity who took this away
and when you research it the answer is
the user
the user is is the problem of the world
all this technological progress
is not beneficial for the ordinary man
yeah because the problems of the working
men
are almost the same uh 10 years ago 50
years ago
100 years ago but it shouldn't be
if you look this technological progress
then the the
the the standard of living and the
capability should be better
but now it's even worse because also 100
years ago
uh it was like say example in the united
states you know
or the beginning of the 20th century
it was normal that the husband works
and he can provide for all of his family
women didn't have to work there used to
be one garage now we have two
i was asking why is there only one
ground some houses back home because it
was like this you're saying yeah one man
could provide for his family
yeah he could feed his family and
the families were bigger there were more
children then women didn't have to go to
work but what what is going on then then
the world world one comes
and it was all part of this strategy
program
you know about zionism
temple and this neural order and they
put
men on the front to wage war for their
interest
and put women in the factories to work
and
when men returned back dwayne remained
in the factory and then the man also
worked so now we have
a husband and wife mother and father
doing the job
and who is pro who is taking care of the
children i i heard
i heard this was systematically set up
also that now
you can you have more people to tax
right right kids are taken
out from the um institution of the home
where the parents are raising them now
the institution is raising them they're
out there in the school
being programmed for a certain night uh
in a certain way that
is conditioning that's it and the user
is the problem
that takes away all these technological
progress yeah
instead of that even now it should be
easier for
men of the of the of the home men of the
family
to provide for hos whole his family so
his wife
can stay home educate kids take care of
the
of the children but you're backwards now
brother we're living in the 20th century
what do you
what that's in the stone age what do you
say what is backwards
what is backwards about taking care of
the children i don't know what is
backwards
in this idea what is backwards that that
that women
you know it's god made them you know to
to to give birth to the children to to
feed them
is the man can you feed the children no
can i you mean breastfeeding
breastfeeding yes breastfeeding babies
so so women women are the ones who can
do it
not us so instead of what is going on
now
instead of breastfeeding babies they're
going they
after soon after they deliver the baby
they have
they have to go back to work and who is
the feeding baby industrial food
you have to buy duster in the the baby
glorify junk food it's destroying the
kids immune system nothing
can replace mother's milk that's the
first
power of nutrition right right that the
crater gave us yeah exactly nothing can
change
be better than that and but now they
have her worrying about what's going to
happen to my breasts is going to
give off yeah all these nonsense ideas
they've been pushed she's been
victimized yeah look at this
hollywood actress how he she looks you
know fit in
also on and people they push
frustrations you know i
don't look like there's like that uh and
then then unfortunately lots of them
think uh
my children are to blame that uh my i'm
out of shape and so on yeah but she's
actually a nation builder right she's
building a nation so you take her from
being a nation builder
to what being uh taking orders is a
secretary of the cocktail waitress or
you know
you went from obeying the creator to
obeying the boss right right but you
have smart women sometimes they go
through
all of this and again islam doesn't like
limit the woman that she cannot you know
whatnot no no
it's it's most important that women that
mothers are educated but yeah because
who is giving the prime minister to be
educated you have who is
who is the first teacher of the of the
children of the babies is the mother
yeah if she is not educated
then the children are not getting proper
education
so i mean would you rather i mean you
get out
you know you know you're shoveling snow
get the car out you know driving in
traffic then you got to get there and
then
you know be mixing around men and then
you hear the disgusting things from the
locker rooms you know how men are
you know talk during lunch break did you
see her look how she looked the curve
this
you know disgusting things deal with all
of this sexual harassment and all that
and then she then finally realized like
man i got it made here actually i got a
guy a law gave me a sugar daddy he takes
care of me i don't
i don't i didn't have to actually work i
don't have to go through this i could be
educated
i could start a business on my own but i
don't have to be mixing with all these
men
you know going through all this
humiliation potential problems
big potential look at all the sex
scandals now that we had
the home of the me too movement right
right especially
in the army you see even now in croatia
as croatia
entered this nato pact and these modern
standards of the military
in the united states its official uh uh
statistics how many of these women
soldiers get abused in the army
it's in the hundreds of thousands what
how many how hundreds of thousands these
are females
demons in the military yeah because it's
unnatural
you know especially in military
environment and i am a military man i i
went through the war and everything i
have good military you know background
and i know what military is the form of
yugoslavia for mangoslavia and in
croatia
independence yeah and uh it's it's
in in especially in the time of war but
even without war
in this when you got you know in boot
camps and everything
it these are extreme conditions you know
even when it's cold you know
as a soldier you know you you sleep in
this
small places in the bunker what what can
woman if a woman is
you know it's uh now you're talking
about close quarter contest yes
she's actually hotter by nature right
right right so so it's uh
and also this is interesting but by only
if you look uh strictly militarily
women's uh distraction in the fight
because of the psychology of men
why yeah no no yes because
you know if we as a man go as a group
uh i don't have even in subliminally
uh urge to protect you as i have urged
to protect
women yeah and the this is breaking up
all the you know tactical level
yeah which we what we are trained so
effectiveness of the military
is uh pushed down by these uh pushing
women
in this side so in the army so the the
question is
what is the reason of this what are they
pushing in pushing it
it's not to to have a better military
but it's to destroy
the society and this is the actual
oppression of women
right so and the sad thing is you're
being oppressed you don't even see it
you see it as liberation but
it's enslavement right exactly and
they're doing it by
all the means it's called uh it's it's
it's in uh official pentagon document
it's called
full spectral dominance i don't know if
you heard about that
full spectre dominance no they have this
it's all suffixed more than 20 years old
this program you know
we will we will uh dominate not only the
sphere of
uh uh classical military action will
dominate in psychology or
in the media in a spiritual sense you
have even in the u.s military
you have this spiritual war yeah
famous guys now he is retired is this
general michael aquino yes you've heard
of him no
yeah you see he was active u.s military
officer
hi hi active u.s military officer for
for
this branch of psychology psychological
warfare
and he parallel with this he founded he
was first
he was first with this guy who founded
in san francisco this
church of satan yeah and then he he
got in some disagreement with this guy
what is his name this church of satan in
san francisco
now remember but he got in some argument
with him and he separately founded the
temple of said
yes this is open pure
satanism it's nothing to to hide you
know
and he is parallel with this with this
open pure satanism that he is a high
priest of that
temple of seth yes he is doing
psychological operation in the u.s army
wow and this is something i put
these links maybe a few years ago on my
facebook
profile i i was astounded when i found
this you know
that officially u.s military
not near military u.s congress has
allowed
into a u.s military servicemen to have
sex with animals because before it was
forbidden
for soldiers to have sex with animals
now it's legally
approved so u.s soldiers can have sex
with animals
this is uh what do you mean i will send
you this link
yeah you can read it how is how this is
uh
bestiality right right how is this i
don't i don't understand
it's madness you know you see it's it's
uh it's
incredible when you see it you cannot
believe but it's true
you will see the u.s congress approved
that no more
u.s uh your soldiers who are found to
have sex
this with animal specialty they won't be
prosecuted
yeah it's so it it's it's another level
of
of of wage against god
and his creation it reminds reminds me
of so many women
you have uh who are reaching
their 50s 60s and they pursued their
careers
they've accomplished you know the
diplomas uh
they missed their fertility window they
didn't have you know a family kids
and they're in a state of regret they're
in a deep state of regret you have
so many because now they've achieved the
worldly things but they're all alone
there's no one to care for them they
didn't have a family they didn't do
these things that are most pleasing to
god almighty the creator pleasing to
them also
to them right to them they they feel
something is missing
something's missing they've been
suckered right right yeah so
now you're going totally in this
direction
that's been painted to you uh by these
dark forces
like go the happiness is here go go get
it but then you're forgetting about the
divine guidance that's been given to you
by allah that's most pleasing
you know for you it's a benefit for you
and then now at the end
you're just like you know europe you
can't get married now you can't
uh you've accomplished all these things
and you're you don't have a family you
don't have the
the beauties the richness of life and uh
then you get into depression
depression the new mental health issues
now right then you
what you go you go to the psychiatrist
and they prescripts you
something that's that's a whole nother
rabbit hole right
yeah and then you you end up you know
uh drugged up yeah totally you know
unhappy and there are lots of suicides
yeah you know lots of people you know uh
at the end of this
this road they they they end up
killing themselves because they don't
see any any
any purpose of life and this is uh
satan's
final victory to to push people to
commit suicide to
give up of the life to offend the the
creator
who gave us this this gift of life yeah
we know that islam has guaranteed rights
and justice
there's nothing i recently had a guest
on who says you know
one one scholar of islam he challenges
people find me one thing
in islam that's harmful for humanity so
there's
there's this liberation there's so many
women and we often ask people
ask them the muslim women why she's
wearing what
jesus mother mary were the hijab the
modest dress and whatnot
and why she accepted there's more women
accepting islam
so that's a whole different topic but
for anyone who wants to research you'll
see
the rights that women were given way
before any woman today
had any of these words but what do you
think when you hear this
this whole movement with uh we'll touch
upon this for a second
this whole feminist movement and all
these things what do you think about
that
it's also part of this global program of
destroying the humanity and pushing them
in the
in the self-destruction is there there
are
giving these false premises that women
are
living hard on the men that they are
discriminated
because you know men are
always beating them and all these
bad stuff going on which is there are
some extreme
examples of that but this is not uh
the nature of men as it is not the
nature of woman
to to to live without to men
because this feminism finally uh
ends up saying we don't need men in our
life it goes through that extremely
right right you don't remain in life
life
it's better without men and if you watch
these uh
hollywood movies all these on tv that
they are producing these
different you know uh
soap operas whatever they are they're
pushing out they're always
having this uh especially in action
action
movies superheroes you see wonder woman
superwoman
that she's you know beating all the men
which is
absolutely out of the reality you know
that small woman maybe
uh 60 70 kilos you know
heavy that she is you know taking some
guy who is
is much stronger and she's beating you
up so so when the small girls are
uh watching this propaganda they say oh
i can beat men
easily you know i can do this i can do
that
whatever they are pushing you know i
don't need man in my life i can
i can dominate as it is shown here in
the movie
but the reality life is completely
different and then there is a clash with
between this perception from the
media propaganda and fro from the post
culture and reality
and uh then when these collide
then there is also problems inside of
them you know
this is why they then unusually lots of
if you've seen these
protests of these feminists they are
hardly aggressive
they are aggressive to the you know
especially especially proclaiming these
rights of
uh killing uh unborn babies you know
they're proclaiming this is all right
we have to right to do it and if you
even try to
i've seen on youtube many of these
examples when somebody is peacefully
just having a sign stop killing babies
these hardcore feminists
come to them and attack them you know
that yeah
they should not have right to their
opinion because
they say just the expression of what you
are thinking
is uh is something that should be banned
and
should be by force you know uh removed
yeah and uh but they don't understand
that uh
they're proclaiming and they they're
even uh labeling them as
no fascist these these you know
etiquettes you know they're putting on
but they don't they don't see
that they themselves are the one who is
making the oppression who are making who
are making the aggression
and who are going against themselves
finally
yeah these are hypocrisy you see
like these are the same people who would
uh be in a frenzy because let's say
a muslim uh wants to circumcise
a baby right it has so many benefits the
traditions from you know
since the beginning and they get in the
frenzy but then you have
you know full uh uh babies in their last
trimester
they're murdering them yeah yeah and
then you get you get the contract
right yeah so circa they want to
champion the uh baby's rights you know
they go crazy because you're gonna
circumcise the foreskin
but it's okay to kill the baby it's okay
it's crazy and even even if you know
what
the term is late term uh abortion yeah
it's abortion after the birth now they
have that yeah yeah they have to have
what like two doctors approve or sorry
and that's it they can do it that's
crazy that's that's
it just keeps sinking lower and lower
this is immorality uh this is uh
really troubling it's really um uh it's
like people been
uh bewitched you know it's like under
spells these satanic dark forces and
people aren't seeing clear that's why
the guidance from the crates there that
we need it more
than ever more than ever yes because
this is
organized on the high level as i said
you see this
this example of this uh michael aquino
is
high us commander of the this
psychological war his parallel with that
this
satanist open satanist no yeah so you
can see that in into the
institutions of the state and all this
corporate media
are those kind of people who are openly
now even without hardy
practicing and advancing this uh
satanism
this luciferianism and all this kind of
of
of madness this morality we're talking
about is something that
any god conscious someone who says yeah
i believe in god you know what i mean
this just makes sense these kind of
things are these are just moral things
that we're bringing to the table shining
light on
i don't know how you know unless the and
these other rich these other things are
just clear paganism this is like modern
day
paganism that's uh running
like a a a a dog with rabies you know
running rampant as they say yeah and
unfortunately people who are
disconnected with the creator
they are much more easily manipulated
and
that's a good point when you disconnect
it from your crater
then it's much more easier not to fall
in this there are thousands of thousands
of traps
no laying around especially for a young
generation for young kings
who are now uh who are in their
development phase
they are not fully formed as a person
and they are
much more vulnerable to this propaganda
to these
all the all the all the uh bad ways
bad directions that they are they have
the opportunity to choose
i often i heard the statement where god
wants to address you
they want to undress you right so we
keep why is it we keep seeing that you
know one time in america
you can get actually a ticket like if
you had the right you know the dress
above the
shin now what's the significant what is
how does that represent freedom
if you're just so uncomfortable and now
it's become above the knee
right tomorrow who's to say that okay
we're going to get it up to the you know
at one point the even the woman who had
you know let's say the skirt above the
knee if the one has it to her thigh
she'll call her hooker
right right but it's leading to that
pretty soon you'll be walking in the g
string you know what i mean
but who sets the trends i'm asking the
media this institution they are setting
the trends and regarding this
the trends are also through the media
pushed to ban
muslim women to have a hijab you know
about it that
hijab should be not allowed
in europe i think in france they even
the they even
had this law that wearing a
hijab if you're a public worker you know
it's not allowed yeah so
they are even prohibiting women who is
free
freely by her own free will wants to
wear hijab
want to cover like mother of jesus did
yeah it's not allowed so i'm talking
here if you're i can
i can understand just for arguments like
if you're not god conscious
why would you want her covered you're no
because the man wants to see more
right he if he can go to the strip club
all the time you know what i mean if you
can get
prostitutes and hookers and have more he
wants to but do you know what
what's when you speak about strip clubs
you know there is one phenomenon
in strip clubs which can explain
something you know
in silver clubs you know all the women
[Music]
walk around completely naked you know
nothing on them yeah
but on the bar there is a waitress
she has at least something gone you know
yes she's dressed
she's dressed and most of the men almost
all
are hitting on her they're hitting on
the one
you see yeah because men uh even
unconsciously
want to to you know to they're hitting
on the person the woman in the
who's uh has the clothes on in the strip
club right right
because even you know what's the
challenge
you know when when everything is open
you know there's no there's no
charm in it there's no respect no no no
no
because there's no this process of
connection you know
discovering each other you know there
should be a
nice natural process to find out
about each other more you know to go
deeper into
into this connection leave some for the
imagination right
but when it's all out in the open you
know
there's no motivation there's no no so
if you're jew if you're christian if
you're a god conscious person right
you can relate to what we're saying
right right but if you're just uh
someone who's
disconnected no morality compass it's
like why would you agree with this
you would actually champion and say like
no no this is uh this is the way to go
forward we're progressing this is
modernity
this is progressing by addressing the
woman yeah it reminds me when they used
to have they
literally did you know they had zoos in
america at one time they had human zoos
no yeah they had human zoos in america
you can look this up
and they were parading at one point uh
you know dr
um norman fickelstein there's a
paraphrasing a statement he made he says
you know when
when the uh when we came over here he
said to the
you know to see the the native americans
and they didn't have clothes on
we called them barbarians we called them
you know all these dirty names because
they were
uncivilized but the the women at that
time and they had three layers of
clothes just like the muslim woman now
the muslim woman is covered like jesus
mother mary she's in this modest dress
and we're calling them uncivilized well
we're naked
it's all everything is upside down yeah
absolutely
i didn't know about this human jews yeah
i know about human jews
in europe belgium king in belgium
had this human jews he he took uh from
uh belgian congo in africa
he took uh slaves and he exposed them in
in bristles
yeah in the same way the same yeah so
this is one of those rabbit holes also
you're just amazed at what humans we
would do they would take you know
uh these were the uh white americans
europeans at that time
who were taking the native americans and
others african-americans and they would
you know
put them in these uh these cages for
people to come see and observe
and like animals right yeah so uh these
are the kind of things
going back to what you were saying that
you discussed there i myself
uh am not a conspiracy theorist even
though this term
i know there was it was created by a
certain organization
to label someone anyone who goes against
the mainstream they'll put this on you
to go ahead and you know have you look
like you're some strange friends element
yes
but i'm just a person like if somebody
comes to me and you know the mainstream
is that there's a santa claus
coming down the chimney uh to ferry i
question these things you know i mean if
something doesn't logically make sense
and this is what islam calls us to be to
be more to be to be
awake to be awakened to question the
allah tells us in the quran if someone
comes to you you know fasik you know a
liar someone comes to you
you need to verify it we need to verify
things uh so that's the kind of person i
am i'm sure you're the same way but i
don't go down these holes looking for oh
this person did this that
i don't do that but there's some things
that are just obvious obviously plain in
the open
and i don't just swallow everything like
no muslims should just swallow
everything that's fit
we have to see how shaytan has his traps
and tricks into this right
and do our research do our due diligence
to search for knowledge
search for knowledge yes be awoken you
know islam
awakens you to the reality and then uh
when i was uh investigating this
uh that you have in your book i see that
this actually brings
uh these concepts these uh what the
creator
allah is talking about in the quran it
brings to life you know ayahs come to
mind they plot uh
they plant plant allah plants allah is
the best of planters
another ayah as it talks about there's
no good in their secret meetings
so it brings the quran the reality of
these things that are happening
that most people they're not aware of it
brings it to light and it connects you
more
with the quran and really the reality of
things that are going on beyond us but
people are just like sheep
following blindly right right and this
is what i'm writing here about
uh we talked about this you know
geopolitical
what's going on today and uh how did
it come to this you know because this
was a long-term process
you know in this situation that we have
this
zionist entity of israel that we have
this
world monetary system which is uh
completely controlled by the zionists in
into their service
and that the world is progressing into
this
uh this is famous term new world order
but what is this new world order
we hear this we hear this term and
that's one of those again you hear this
and you think okay this is just like
some
conspiracy theorists and they're just
you know uh
you know uh making some stuff up and
you're like i don't have time for that
but
there's some things behind the scenes
that are going on and what is this term
but
they're not regarding this term it is
not even behind
the the the scenes you know uh you can
find you know in this in the public
speeches of
george bush senior and even before these
uh high-level
politicians they are openly saying we
will
bring up we will build up this new world
order yeah the
the they are they pushed this term into
the public sphere you know
uh what does this mean though what is it
when you hear this what does this
actually mean
it means you know uh this is
the new world order is the now we are
going into
we must have this theological awareness
we hear globalization
with the world order what is this but
what is the final goal you know the
final
one the center this is what i'm writing
in the center of the geopolitical
uh movement movement on on in this world
is in jerusalem is uh in
to be concrete it's uh dome of the rock
everything is going you know uh
collaborated with the dome of the rock
because the final
final uh stage of this new world order
and the new world order cannot be
finalized without rebuilding of the
third temple
so this is like uh trying to facilitate
uh when i
looking into it this fulfillment of some
prophecy right right because in islam
there's prophecies there's things that
the prophet muhammad and
they talked about but we don't try to
expiate this right you know make things
and this is christianity in bible there
are also prophecies
so and there are in judaism judaism
uh there are also prophecies and
especially in talmudic judaism this is
there is differentiation between you
know uh talmudic
judaism and torah judaism so torah is
is what we believe as muslims was given
in its original
we don't have it's original this is lost
it's lost but what was given it's
original
moses we believe in this right right so
then tamurik would be totally this is
the human beings tafsir this is what
they're conspiring
this is what they're conspiring from
their minds making up stuff
uh but this is not divinely sent no no
this is not but they say it is
you know you have to trust them you say
the the beginning of the talmudic uh
religious concept is that talmud is
above torah so that's that would
that's like saying it's above divine
right exactly so we can't accept that
because torah is mentioned in the quran
what was given to moses and it's
original we have to accept that he was
given this divine scripture
right right and here they say talmud is
about torah
and uh so in a way
man is man as as a human being is
uh building himself up above the creator
yeah
so let's uh this prophecy
so people can understand this is found
where in the torah that they're saying
or is this in the talmud
this is in there in there okay so again
this is now
human um con
human concepts that are put and that
they're
deriving this from that right right
human but uh
my this is my interpretation not only
human but but
this dark spiritual background is is in
this
uh dark you're gonna have shaytanic
forces who are okay so now
inspiring such such uh such a prophecies
so then
what do you have now you have this based
on this is not divine guidance
these prophecies and now this has to do
with al-aqsa we have three holy places
you know you have a mecca medina and
then you have al-aqsa for the most
right uh this is where all the prophets
have met right
right so we have a deep history here and
now what are they saying with this
prophecy supposed to happen that they're
trying to facilitate it
uh this is this new lord and this uh
ruler of their they're waiting so
talmudic jews
they're waiting for the messiah they
don't accept
jesus no but he came they don't jesus
jesus yes
if you pay j e high school j e s u s
let's take off the j because there were
no jays in the hebrew or aramaic
what do you have issa isa issues right
that's the one that mentioned the quran
in creation we pronounce it issues in
croatia's issues
right right so this is uh uh
he is um we were saying that
he's not he's he's for talmudic
judaism he's not the messiah not only
that
jesus is not the messiah but in talmud
you can find these verses where he's
written
horrible things about jesus and his
mother now you can
verify this right right about about uh
jesus and his
i want to make a disclaimer here right
uh you had this is very important
because
uh you cannot as a muslim be
anti-semitic
right because the prophets jesus was
semitic uh
you know prophet muhammad was semitic so
it's oxymoron you cannot be that's just
you even had scholars at that time
who looked in jews came in that area
expecting
a prophet to come that was prophet
muhammad peace be upon him
and there was many scholars who accepted
islam right i remember a
funeral procession that was going you
know that and the prophet
said the prophet uh the final messenger
said the mankind prophet muhammad peace
be upon him he stood up
and the companion said why are you
standing up right it's a jewish
procession he said isn't that a human
soul right right right so we don't
hate no no any group of people we hate
injustices that have done so i just
wanted to make this
disclaimer we have so many jews coming
to islam we have to treat every human
being with dignity
honor and respect right and here in my
book uh this second chapter
i have this discussion with one croatian
jew who
your friend my friend exactly my friend
who is now late no more ally but he was
my good friend
and he was you can say the
principle honorable jew who who was a
hardcore anti-zionist yeah i have a good
friend uh he's an israeli jewish mikko
pillar
right right he's a friend of mine i have
a rabbi weiss i've had him on the
program
you know these are i would say you know
people uh mikko's a friend of mine these
are so there's nothing like
like we hate these people this that now
it's about getting to the bottom of
things and getting to the truth
right right so where are we going what
are we saying so
there's these prophecies in this
talmudic concept and
the main thing is they don't believe
jesus is the messiah they're waiting for
their messiah to come
this would solve the problem right now
if they accept jesus
which hundred percent right hundred
percent there's no doubt about it
the evidence is clear how can you miss
this this is deep
he is the messiah he's not god literal
son of god
he's the messiah that is the messenger i
will now represent their side go ahead
they their argument is if jesus was the
messiah
then he would then conquer whole the
world
and bring peace in all the world when he
comes back he will wow
they wanted them then to do it oh they
want to do it on their time right right
they want their terms they don't want to
subject to the gods you know will
yeah they want their terms to be as they
want it to be yeah
that's the problem that's the problem
so now if i'm understanding this
correctly so they want to facilitate
this building of the temple of jerusalem
right
right
and that now is where masjid aksar is
so they want to remove this uh
al-aqsa and the more important even the
under
this exact place where the third temple
should be built
is the this uh dome of the rock this
golden
you know when you see these pictures of
jerusalem there's this golden
uh the picture we see is not actually
its back
that's not the real one right which one
the the picture of uh masjid aksar
you know the real big there's there's
it's behind uh
this with the golden dome yeah this is
not al-aqsa this is dom of the rock
that's the dome of the rock
uh the al-aqsa is 100 meters
on the side on the side and it's the
dome is silver
so which one do they want to destroy uh
this
with golden the golden dome so the
masjid xr
is not going to be probably will too
because it's
nearby you know but the the focus point
is this dome of the rock this is the
exact place where uh the temple should
be rebuilt because
previously first and second temple were
there so this is not a
conspiracy theory anyone who investigate
this uh
you can see that this is politicians
everybody's talking about it if you go
to the except the muslims
yes unfortunately but we are muslims and
we are talking about it yes
if you go to jerusalem you can find in
jerusalem just nearby this
temple mount is the temple institute
run by talmudic jews
you can go inside you can you can even
online
see what's going on and they are uh
preparing for the rebuild of the third
temple
openly it's nothing hidden it's openly
totally that they are proclamating this
they are uh
they're wanting to push it up to hurry
it up you know
yeah as soon as possible everything is
ready you know
they're preparing services they're
preparing all these uh
temple regalia you know
these candlesticks whatever they they
need
everything is prepared even even stones
are prepared nearby
everything's getting in preparation i
heard that everything is years ago this
was
this started off as just talk but then
it facilitated into mainstream
yeah i see the mainstream like
washington post what's the uh
the newspaper out there jerusalem
they've talked about it
they're talking about it and in the
political sphere
in this netanyahu coalition government
because netanyahu is this liquid party
but they cannot form uh on its own he
has to go into coalition with these
small extreme right
radical groups you know
who who are pushing for this but also
netanyahu is
she he's just more you know he seems to
be more
uh more liberal should you say but
they are all pushing for for this
rebuilding of the third temple and the
trump
president trump u.s president uh
he he's in this temple institute you can
find gold coins that they
that are melted you know coined with
trump and cyrus the great because they
are
seeing the trump and they're portraying
the trump as the cyrus the great
cyrus the great was the persian emperor
who liberated jews from the babylon
babylonian slavehood
and return them back to jerusalem and
allow them and help them to rebuild
the temple it was the rebuilding of the
second half because the first temple was
destroyed
and the cyrus the great help them
rebuild the second temple
now they are portraying and pushing
trump
as a personification of even
reincarnation because
but we don't believe in recreation but
they are spinning
this way or the cyrus the great and that
he will help
this zionist jews to rebuild the temple
as the side of the great did
two and two and a half thousand years
ago yes they have pictures uh when
politicians american politicians come
i've seen that they actually have a
blueprint of it right right drawn up
and they're showing not only blueprint
they have this small scale you know
how they say you know small scale
model yeah model of the temple
everything is there you know
and by all the means they are pushing
this
rebuilding of the third temple but to
rebuild it they have to destroy dome of
the rock
and the uh probably
uh al-aqsa mosque but these are all holy
muslim places
and it's our obligation
to do whatever it can you know to to
stop them to
not let them do it because a lot of
world war lots of pain
if they go in this move because uh
without destruction they cannot do it
and the
distractions means you know that uh
war will will wage uh
but war uh war is waging right now but
uh it will wage on much
larger scale and so tell us more about
this prophecy so
what are they expecting they're
expecting to build this
to remove masjid aksar to build this
temple the the jerusalem temple
so that's why they call it the third
temple because
the second temple was destroyed near uh
so what first one destroyed second
destroyer destroyed so this would be the
third
that's how we got third temple right
temple mount temple mount on temple
mount this this whole area this whole
complex is called temple mount
okay so now they want to review this
sacred
i mean you really got to just you know
be way out there you
to do something so vile and oppressive
to a people you want to just
take this sacred they know this is so
sacred to the muslims
they say it's more sacred to them yeah
uh so now you don't what do what do the
real
orthodox uh jews like the rabbis these
the ones that were originally there were
against right now
so you have these uh jews rabbis that
they are now in
minority who are anti-zionist and their
concept
their their interpretation they're the
real jews right
their interpretation of of this problem
is hold on uh we must
unfortunately they also don't recognize
jesus as messiah they also wait for the
messiah
but they are anti-zionist why because
they say
we cannot rebuild the third temple we
must wait
for messiah to come he will rebuild it
these are anti-zionists saying this and
they are against
the state of israel and they are not
jews these are jews
there are jews against this is one of
them you know
the chief jew of of palestine at that
time the chief movement
i say mufti jew like you would say the
chief he was also against
right because they were living together
in peace with muslims there wasn't this
catastrophe that happened now
jews and muslims were living together
watching each other's kids everything
was very
calm and peaceful right and these now
they
come these zionist jews zionist rabbis
and they are now unfortunately their
dominant one and they have all the power
and they are saying no no we shall not
wait for the messiah to come
we must rebuild the temple because when
we rebuild it
then messiah will come he won't come
he's waiting for us to build it
when we build it then he will come and
this is the reason why they are pushing
for this
temple to be revealed because their
their belief is that
without rebuild of this third temple
messiah won't come no they're just
wasting her time because he came already
and at the same time you're undermining
you know the plan of the divine you
don't like hurry up god's
missions whatever is going to happen you
don't make it on your time clock
there's no proof we have proof where if
you had it's different you had something
divinely sent and we can go ahead and
scrutinize it saying that this is 100
from god this is what he wants you to do
you don't have that like for instance
god almighty sent to all the messengers
that you worship god almighty alone hero
is where the lord thy god is one
this is clear he never revealed trinity
he never revealed any of these pagan
concept
pure monotheism that's 100 proof for
that right that jesus was a messenger
100 percent proof that moses was a
messenger that prophet muhammad is the
last and final messenger
these are tangible things that you can
scrutinize the evidence that okay the
quran is a testable book
you can look at it examine it as it was
revealed back then we have it today
memorized by millions prophecies in
there
there are facts not fiction you can test
the book yes if
you uh if you're honest if you are
you you you take your time to to
research it
you will find the answer you can
actually they've done a study this is a
study a scientific study
that you can even differentiate they've
done this analysis where the words of
the quran
and the words of prophet muhammad that
they have they have done studies
that i can send you the article um i had
one of my guests send this to me
that you know how we have the quran and
this is the verbatim speech of the
divine of allah the creator
and then they have the hadith authentic
the
muhammad they've they've decoded that
these are totally different than these
right right so this is how we can we can
challenge and test
and when we have a chain this is science
a chain linking back
all the way to prophet muhammad there's
no chain here no
looking to moses or anything nothing
else is all
make believe you know yeah so now now
this is like drama show
like it's just making major drama like
shakespeare said all
the the whole world is a stage you know
yeah and they're playing this drama
and they have actress and they have a
director in the background
yeah and they have their script and
they're playing by the script
and this script is you know we must
rebuild the third temple
and then this messiah will come and he
will give us
worldly rules he will we will rule all
the world
this is this talmudic judaism concept
you have uh
you know iraq uh invaded
uh how many millions of people killed on
the presence of
weapons of mass destruction uh you have
uh today you know kashmir
the uber muslims two million plus uh
making these examples because
uh muslims some some of those peace you
in every group you have fringe elements
that do crazy you know things opposite
to islam actually
but you have these uh muslims who want
to make their fight daily prayers they
have a guarant we have
actually uh a general guarantee for
paradise
if we are god conscious we live on the
pure toll heed
we do good deeds so we want to help make
this more peaceful sustainable peace for
all
right right share this message not to
force anything
so we just want to live peacefully but
these people bringing the drama
attacking blowing up stuff and then
flipping the script and say you're the
terrorist right right this is this is
modus operandi how they're working
exactly and
this is it we must see what they're
doing
not be ignorant not to turn our head
away
especially when we see our brothers it
doesn't matter if
muslim or muslim when we see another
human being and the other group of
people
who are oppressed who are suffering who
are uh uh
under injustice uh we are obligated to
to help them as as much as possible we
can
if we turn our head on the other way
ignore this uh injustice then
we are not on the right path but it
doesn't mean like some people construe
like oh to put a bomb on yourself and to
go kill innocent
children we're not talking about this
script this is playing in today's script
to do these things you know
and this is why they established this
so-called islamic state
which is also there is no no problem to
prove it that cia
mossad all these uh secret agency
are behind the creation of so-called
islamic state this
isis you know someone mentioned
something about
isis standing for i i didn't say this
i'm just quoting so i've heard this
israeli secret intelligence service
right
it's from the mouth of the is israeli uh
intelligent uh uh from inside
insider inside uh when an insider
interesting
so when you come back let's say this
prophecy they say
what are they expecting if they build
this
and what are they expecting then to
happen the messiah comes and what
happens then to
all the because you also have christians
who are
being misled and they're following
christian zionism
so what happens what what's the scheme
of thing what is the plot what happens
when they rebuild it and what's supposed
to facilitate from there
when they rebuild it they say then
messiah will appear
and he will establish world peace and
when you listen them it sounds very
[Music]
reasonable and uh uh and peaceful
but how this world peace would look you
know
that uh them as a jews as a
god's chosen people they are literally
this is also in talmudic you know
ideology
written that they are the only
representation of men true
truly made by god on god's image
all other non-jews are on the lower
level
you know uh even on the level of animals
and god have created us non-jews these
the zionists are saying this
talmudic
so we are all made to look to appear
human but we are in fact animals
made as a human so we can uh better
serve them
so it's more pleasing to them for us to
serve so when then
messiah comes every jew this is talmudic
interpretation the tamudis are saying
right every jew will have
some 2000 i don't know 648 i don't know
exact number in some
it's these terms uh uh non-jews
goem as they say going slaves can this
be academically
like verified and researched you can
hear it
and them saying it i will send you all
these links
uh adam green is doing a great job
regarding this you know
everybody can go on his channel he got
he's got plenty full of information
adam green and also other youtube
channel
israeli news live which is run by
uh american jew and he is also
putting this all so this is another uh
israeli who's running this uh
he's american he's a american jew who is
having this uh
israelite is called israeli news live
yeah
and he's also explaining much better
than me he because he is
american he speaks english and you can
find
plentiful information about this what i
am talking about so what's going to
happen to the christians now who are
support the christians who have been
misled by this work because there's a
lot of christians who haven't
been suckered by this they don't fall
into this but it's a shame that
you have a lot of you know politicians
and
you know christians who claim to be
christian
uh even though jesus doesn't support any
of this
so what happens to them to the
christians yeah
well the from the talmudic perspective
for modis you know
there will be all slaves of the jews and
they they will follow the
this messiah this peace everybody who
will not be
willing to subject and recognize this
messiah that they are waiting who is not
jesus yeah who is not jesus
no from their perspective he will be
eliminated
okay um this is a strange relationship
right this is really strange
so if this comes there's really no
benefit
to the christians here they're going to
be yeah this but these christians are
honest
their reasoning is okay we know that
they are not now recognizing jesus but
when
we rebuild the temple yes the antichrist
will come into the temple
but this will hurry up you know the
the the coming back of the jesus who
will defeat the antichrist
and then all these jews who who
didn't recognize jesus then they will
recognize him as a true messiah this is
their reason
so we are helping them to rebuild the
temple so we hurry up
you know speed up the return of the
jesus by you know
by uh helping the antichrist you know
it's a completely
complete madness so on one end these
that
these uh from this the tamudis
uh they're it's gonna actually eliminate
them
uh or enslave them right and then the
other ones when the ends of times
i think in revelation in the bible they
talk about this where jesus the prince
of peace
who again we we don't say any um
uh thing that is negative about jesus
because he's a great messenger in islam
you know saying any filthy dirty
thinking and you land you in a hellfire
say peace be upon him but
according to the bible in revelations it
talks about
at these end of time that jesus is going
to come with a sword you know
from his mouth right right he's going to
slay his enemies so
they believe now that these are the
enemies if they don't accept
jesus as their lord and savior now
they're going to slay them
right right jesus is going to enslave
them right so
it's a kind of uh uh unique relationship
a unique relationship
right yeah and everybody has his own
reasoning yeah
and they they now in this uh
together you know they made a pact and
they try to push this rebuilding of the
temple momentarily
big of course uh this
he's openly proclaiming himself as a
christian zionist mike pompeo
is us secretary of state at the moment
mike pompeo is hardcore christian
zionist
and he is all and all these uh
evangelical preachers in the united
states with their flock you know
they are preaching this theology we must
love israel we must
help israel we must you know uh without
any
uh doubt you know give them all the help
to rebuild
to to establish this third temple
because this will you know speed up the
return of the jesus yeah
and he will save us all but you have on
one end i mean we're we're actually
closer to the christians if you look at
uh the respect and honor we give to
jesus's mother
on one end you have a certain group of
people saying that she's you know
uh the most violent i don't even repeat
the most disgusting things that they say
about her
i think you can verify this uh and also
saying that jesus will be in the depths
of hell fire
over here if we even said something
close to that we can end up in the
hellfire
we say peace be upon him right and this
is that christian uh
owen benjamin who who actually he
recognized that
he recognized how much respect and
reverence and then many of his followers
they also they
we had so many comments of people saying
you don't remember me
i have lots of comments here as i am
muslim
the ignorant people who say now you are
muslim you betrayed jesus
you know yeah what do you say to that
you're absolutely wrong you know i
didn't betray jesus and
now as a muslim i i even more
closer to jesus you know that i was
before because i now know
more clearly what is all about and
without these
false you know uh ideas that uh
as as a christian i had you know jesus
is god and uh
this holy trinity and so on so so i am
now even more close to jesus
there is no betrayal because they don't
know they literally don't know that
muslims
respect jesus love jesus and that jesus
is
also their prophet they're messengers of
god they don't know it
they think muslims are only you know
connected uh following muhammad
peace be upon him and this is it
muhammad and nothing else yeah
it's it's a complete ignorance and
then there are in this state of
ignorance ignorance
they are sticking labels you know you
betrayed jesus you hate jesus
and so on there's too many if you we got
to
be rational logical if you look at the
evidence
if you look at you know not even we go
to the quran if you just look the clear
evidence the clear verses
compared to the ambiguous right if you
look at you know we honor him and
respect him as even in i believe in in
in acts he talks about uh here oh men of
israel jesus
of nazareth a man approved by god
with wonders and miracles that god did
by him
he talks about the father is greater
than i you can't you know he's
subordinate to a higher being to the
creator
uh god doesn't take orders but jesus was
taking orders from the creator
so as much as you manipulate the text
and twist it to mean this and that
uh you know i and the father are one
these these vague verses before abraham
was i
am in the beginning was the word the
words with god if you compare that to
the clear verses you know the father is
greater than i i can and myself do
nothing
clear why do you call me good there's
none but good but one
god of the day or an hour knows no man
you know neither the angels nor the son
but the father alone
it shows that he was a human being but
not just like any human being
he was a prophet a messenger conveying
the message that god almighty sent
through him like moses and abraham and
the prophet muhammad peace be upon him
calling people to only worship one god
hero israel the lord thy god
that's logical it makes sense absolutely
but then you get emotional and the
church programmed you to believe a
certain way and you have this storyline
and then it's
not based on ev clear proof and evidence
and now you're
you're your heart is attached to that
instead of the clear evidence improved
but as i said yesterday you know okay
i have my belief as a muslim you yeah we
have our beliefs
christians have diff uh small
differences we don't have to fight about
it
right you should not fight about it
let's see
what uh what connects us together we
believe in jesus okay
you as a christian believe in jesus uh
as a messenger of god
i do also uh that's a good point yeah
they also believe he's a messenger right
right
yeah so the bible said he's a respecter
right
so we believe that uh jesus is alive yes
where is he he's in heaven right we
believe also so
now you're connecting more commonality
commonalities we believe that jesus will
come back
do yeah we raise our hands yeah where is
what is our differences you believe he
is god
we don't believe he is god okay i can
leave you your faith to you
my faith to me but we believe that he
will come back and we both believe that
he will come back
so when he comes back he will solve our
differences
and who's the god that you believe in
the god jesus believed
that's it that's it there should be no
problem at all between muslims and
christians
because jesus instead they they made it
this way that
question of jesus is separation between
uh christians and
and muslims but jesus should uh put us
close together peace be upon him peace
be upon him right yeah
and then uh and then if you look at it
being a true christian
in the gospels you have honor your
father and mother look uh that this is
uh in the gospel of matthew where they
came to jesus and said oh god master
what good thing and i do that i may have
eternal life
why do you call me good he says there's
one good but god and if you want to
enter an eternal life keep the
commandments then he list the command
thou shall not commit adultery
thou shall not lie still you know honor
your father mother and then
love your neighbor as you love yourself
and this is not restricted to
you know just another christian this is
for your neighbors
yeah everybody uh he even talked about
loving your your enemies
right right so why are you hating the
muslims so much
it's a program it's a program of this
programming programming yes programming
because who is benefiting from this
that's a question
who is benefiting from this who is
benefiting from this
uh rise of hatred and the in in
ignorance because when
when you ain't no knowledge when you
know these facts these things
then you cannot there is no place for
the hate yeah
but when you are put in the state of
negro ignorance through all this media
as we said through all this
false education for all these all this
means of uh
hypnotizing and uh
pushing people in the wrong directions
then they can
make this you know hatred and uh
like people are like programmed you know
and then just push the buttons
and people react emotionally without
reason without reasoning
they pull they react emotionally and
then uh
all although all bad things happen yeah
and then
and then you then we cannot focus on
more of those because there's so much
commonality like we talk about
abortion immorality losing our children
to much of the materialism
those are things common good things that
we agree on we can work on
right right with some things we ate
because husband and wife they don't
agree on certain things you have
republican and democrat in the same
house
they don't agree we're jews and
christian neighbors we can agree to
disagree on some things but there's
other greater things that we can agree
on let's work towards a common good
true christians are against abortion
right yeah muslims who are
real muslims are against abortions great
we can
we can work together to stop this
abortion you know or killing of babies
no matter if they are christian or
muslim or jew or
atheist we don't want to to to have
babies kill in the bad rooms
so we can there are still plenty of
areas
we can work together on mutual benefit
let's finish off we're almost out of
time you talked about dealing with
hurt and pain also in your book right
right the
hurt and pain it was my personal
personal
experience it was during you know these
clashes with police
when i was hurt i had this broken my
neck
i had this pain in my your neck was
broke uh uh
yes here on the fracture fracture yes
yes because when police you know
put me on the floor you can see it on
youtube how it was all done five
policemen got
on top of me you know they they they so
forcefully know
moved my head and crushed me so wow so i
had these problems
and it was hard hard pain that i was
going
for for for for weeks for weeks going on
without you know without even sleep
how hard this pain was
and god thanks to god you know
i overcame this also
by some not to say miracle but
my help of my friends
who uh connected me with
this therapy with cold showers you know
because i tried everything i tried
massages i
went to the doctors to make medical
treatments
nothing helped nothing helped but
eventually what helped me
was you know going under the cold shower
and all these
change of you know habits uh for example
not to drink coffee
yeah for example coffee i don't drink
coffee because uh
coffee has these negative effects on
your metabolism
and it makes you harder to recover
when you you have any health issues so
so by doing this cold shower i finally
recovered you know and i could
function normally this is in short short
version of all this
and here in book i i'm describing this
this period of
enormous pain and how it
affected me you know and
how balance with this
loss of pain i put
a lot of love you know so
and this is kind of it's kind of
uh like uh product so so
to to come you know to to
[Music]
true revelation to true knowledge you
must go
through process of pain nothing comes
easy
there is a culture here in especially in
western civilization you know
i want everything and want it easy
without
putting any effort into it without even
the pain because
whatever even studying you know it's not
easy you know
uh it is it requests you you know to
to sit you know to to give lots of
effort you know to
to do the job or whatever job other
you're doing you know
you must put lots of uh your energy into
it
and sometimes you suffer you suffer it's
the process of life
but this suffering it can go two ways
it can crash you you can you know you
can can stop you
or if you overcome it it makes you
stronger
and this this this extreme pain
made me extremely more stronger when i
overcome it
it made me not to be afraid of
some
things that most of people are afraid
you know what will happen to me if i
speak
this and that okay i agree with you lots
of time i hear
from people yes yes marco i agree with
you completely
but if i say this then i will lose my
job i will have problems
and so on and so on this is also kind of
pain that he's afraid of
he's he's enslaved by this potential
pain
and potential hardship that he knows
that he'll face
and this is holding him back and people
there
it's holding people back for doing the
right thing and i'm saying no
you should not be afraid of that you
should
kind of embrace this problem embrace the
play and
deal with them and you will see with god
helps
you will overcome them not by your own
strength
because also here nothing is resolved
with purely my
own will and strength no no with god's
help
it's overcome but i have to also
actively perceive
precipitate in this not to be passive
and
this is seeing what we what we said
unfortunately lots of muslims today
are too passive you know they're they're
only watching and they're not
uh taking the initiative to resolve the
problems
to see what's going on uh to to they
have
we must we have the best solution it's
given to us
we have all the answers but it's not
proper this is my interpretation okay we
have the best solution
we don't have to do nothing allah will
provide it allah will solve it without
me
without my participation no no no you
are also called
to give your effort into this
uh resolving of whatever problem that
there is not to be
you know so uh uh
lazy even you know and afraid to to
to go into into battle and to to go into
resolving problems facing your enemies
facing the problems
and with faith and if you are honest if
your
intentions are good and honest and you
are sincere
then there is no doubt that god will
help you
god will protect you god will give you
uh
instructions in any which way there is
because
uh everything is under god's command
every
he he he controls the whole history
and we have just to be conscious of that
and to
to to see these signs as we begin this
this our conversation this sign of green
oak is one of these signs
which which is here given to us you see
i can do
what no man can do it's it's in
in front of your face don't don't have a
doubts don't don't
don't be afraid of these worldly powers
don't be afraid of this
zionist they have of course they have
all the control of the
complete world monetary system they have
all the control of the
most mighty military power in the in the
world united states
yes they have these mighty weapons they
have this
media uh control hollywood control
cultural control yes they have all this
worldly power
but there is a power above them that
created all that
that they are holding the one who
created everything
he is the one with real power and we
should lean on this power
you should have trust in his power and
not be afraid of them
be afraid of allah what will he say to
you
when you face the final judgment this is
this is the the final uh
experience of this process of going
through the pain
and coming to the uh from the extreme
pain to do this big love that
that is that is there waiting for us to
to embrace us to to
to give us strength to to whatever we
need
we will have it i really enjoyed talking
with you
how can people because the book is now
we're talking to an english audience
but the book is not in english it's not
in english it should be
translated to english but there are lots
of things if there is a good idea if
there is a sponsor
who wants to translate to take this
project on right they can go and contact
you
right and they can go ahead and call you
or me
you can contact uh marco directly and go
ahead you can find them where can they
find you on facebook
on facebook yes my facebook profile
that's a good one if you if you uh want
to sponsor the translation of this book
in english
yes there are lots of we didn't have
time to
to touch on these items
here at what i write about this
geopolitical you know context about cold
war
east and west and how all this big stage
you know
and how it was prepared you know for the
zionist project
all these informations are here
explained so when the
reader reads it he'll be in better
understanding
how it was done and when you know how it
was done then you can know better
what will be next and how to prepare
how to have the proper answers for what
is coming yeah
but the but the book is in if you're
bosnian croatian
serbian that that language you can
understand yes yes it's
everybody can understand it it's a it's
a common look
inshallah we get it translated in many
years uh
languages and hopefully first we get
into english and get it out there we can
be talking about thank you so much
thank you it's very nice thank you eddie
nice to see you and
inshallah see you again inshallah god
willing and we started with peace and we
end with peace because that's a greeting
of jesus
it's a greeting of moses abraham and the
last and final messenger sent to mankind
prophet muhammad peace and blessings be
upon them all
so we're people of peace trying to live
peace with our creator peace within
ourselves
and if you like what we talked about you
have some feedback leave it in the
comments below
and you can do your small part and share
help create awareness
getting the truth out there family and
friends and others
and we'll see you next time subscribe if
you haven't already so you can get all
the latest programs that we put out
there
and we'll see you next time here on the
deen show god will inshallah until then
peace be with you assalamu alaikum from
sarajevo